>>> WHY?
HAPPY FRIDAY, AMERICA.
TONIGHT IS A SPECIAL NIGHT.
IT IS FEMININE FRIDAY.
WHERE ALL THE PANELISTS ARE
WOMEN.
TONIGHT WE HAVE KENNEDY,
McDOWELL AND JANINE GARROTTE
BELOW.
I HOPE YOU HAD A GOOD WEEK.
I DID, NO THANKS TO HOWARD
STERN.
THE NEW YORK TIMES POST REPORTED
THAT STERN HIT A CHIC RESTAURANT
AT NYC WITH THE CREW OF A
LISTERS INCLUDING JIMMY KIMMEL,
JENNIFER ANISTON, JOHN HAMM,
JUSTIN THOREAU, JASON BATEMAN.
I WAS NOT INVITED.
I GUESS BECAUSE MY FIRST NAME
DOESN'T BEGIN WITH THE LETTER J.
DID YOU NOTICE THAT?
IT'S OKAY.
I HAD OTHER THINGS TO DO THAT
EVENING.
♪ MUSIC PLAYING ♪
IMAGINE A CONVERSATION WITH THAT
GROUP.
HOW IS YOUR HEALTH?
TWO BOOSTERS AND ECHO NATION.
AND I ONLY GOT COVID FOR TIMES.
I DID A TRIPLE BACKS PLUS I GAVE
DR. FAUCI A REACH AROUND.
HE SAID COME ON JIMMY, DON'T
WORRY ABOUT YOUR SOFA.
I AM NOT A SUPERSPREADER.
THE DINNER IS IN THE STORY.
IT'S WHAT HOWARD SAID LATER ON
HIS RADIO SHOW.
QUOTE, I REALLY HAD AN
EXHAUSTING WEEKEND.
EMOTIONALLY, PHYSICALLY, FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN TWO YEARS I
VENTURED OUT OF THE HOUSE.
MAY BE HE'S EXAGGERATING.
WE ALL DO THAT.
THE MORE SUCCESSFUL AND YOU GET
IN MEDIA, THE MORE EXHAUSTING
THE EASIEST THINGS BECOME.
THIS IS TRUE.
I GUESS THAT EXPLAINS THE
BOUNDLESS ENERGY.
IT'S TRUE.
STUFF I DID 20 YEARS AGO LIKE
HAILING A CAB OR BUYING MY OWN
LUNCH OR SHAVING MY BACK, I HAVE
OTHER PEOPLE DO THAT NOW.
AGAIN, A BIG THANKS TO TREVOR
NOAH FOR HELPING ME WITH THE
LITTLE DAY-TO-DAY STUFF.
IS HE YOUR BEST FRIEND?
IS HE CALLING YOU UP AND SAYING
HELLO?
NO.
THAT'S HOW STERN CAN CALL
STACKING WITH CELEBS EXHAUSTING.
EXHAUSTING, FLAKY LIKE HE
FINISHED THE OVERNIGHT SHIFT IN
A COAL MINE OR HEARING CAP CAT
TALK ABOUT HER PETS.
BUT I GET IT.
LIFE IS TOUGH, ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU HAVE BEEN CUT OFF FROM THE
WORLD FOR 2 YEARS IN A
$20 MILLION BEACH HOUSE.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA HOW TIRING IT
IS WALKING FROM THE WINE CELLAR
TO THE TENNIS COURT AND BACK.
DO I SOUND JEALOUS?
YES.
WHO WOULDN'T BE?
DON'T GET ME WRONG, I AM DOING
JUST FINE.
HE MAY HAVE HIS OWN PRIVATE
BEACH, BUT I HAVE SO ON A ROPE.
IT COMES IN HANDY WHEN YOU'VE
GOT COMPANY.
LIKE HOWARD, FOR A SPELL I
RETREATED TO A CABIN IN THE
WOODS DURING THE LOCKDOWN.
NOT FOR LONG, BUT I DID HAVE TO
FEED THE TEENS IN THE ROOT
CELLAR.
THEY GROW UP SO FAST.
RATE THROUGH THE ROPES.
STERN BEING HOLED UP IN HIS
HOUSE THAT LONG EXPLAINS A LOT
OF THINGS.
LIKE HOW YOU FORGET HOW OTHER
PEOPLE LIVE, ESPECIALLY IN HARD
TIMES LIKE A PANDEMIC.
FOR THE LONGEST TIME, TWO YEARS,
THE SAME TIME STERN HAS BEEN A
WALL, I WHERE HE WENT, NOT
PHYSICALLY, BUT MENTALLY.
REMEMBER HIS TALKS ABOUT COVID.
THEY WERE EPIC AND ANGRY AND NOT
TO MENTION WRONG.
>> WHEN ARE WE GOING TO STOP
PUTTING UP WITH THE IDIOTS IN
THE COUNTRY AND SAY IT'S
MANDATORY TO GET VACCINATED.
I WANT MY FREEDOM TO LIVE.
>> THIS GUY MAKES ANTHONY FAUCI
SOUND LIKE A CANADIAN TRUCKER.
MAYBE HE SHOULD FOLLOW HIS NEXT
VACCINE WITH A SHOT OF VALIUM.
IT'S WEIRD.
HE WENT FROM RIDICULING THE MAN
TO BECOMING HIM.
NO LONGER EMBRACING REBELLION,
HE FRENCH KISSES REGULATION.
HE WENT FROM MOCKING A RADIO
EXECUTIVE WHO WAS A RIGID BY THE
BOOK A WHOLE THAT HE NAMED PIG
VOMIT TO BEING PIG VOMIT
HIMSELF.
HE WENT FROM HOWARD STERN TO
HOWARD HUGHES AND LOST THE
CONNECTION TO HUMANITY.
HE WENT FROM HANGING OUT WITH
THIS TO HANGING OUT WITH THIS.
IT'S HARD TO SAY WHO'S HAD MORE
PLASTIC SURGERY.
HOWARD WENT FROM GETTING PEOPLE
TO FARK SONGS OUT OF THERE BUT
TO COMMISERATING WITH THE SUPER
WEALTHY ABOUT THE EVILS OF TRUMP
WHO WAS A GUEST ON HOWARD'S SHOW
MANY TIMES.
I GET IT.
HE HAS NEW FRIENDS AND BRINGS
NEW VIEWS.
AT CELEBRITY PEER PRESSURE.
THE FACT HE HASN'T LEFT HIS
HOUSE IN TWO YEARS MEANS HIS
VIEWS RBS.
HE WAS IN A HAPPY SELF-IMPOSED
LOCKDOWN WITH A MANSION ON THE
BEACH AND LIMITLESS OPTIONS FOR
FOOD AND ENTERTAINMENT.
THAT'S NOT REAL LIFE.
THAT'S A TWO YEAR ALL-INCLUSIVE
VACATION AT BARBADOS.
WHICH IS IMPOSSIBLE FOR EVERYONE
ELSE IN LOCKDOWN INCLUDING
ESPECIALLY HIS LISTENERS.
HE WAS DOING HIS SHOW FROM HOME.
I'M SURE YOU COULD WORK FROM
HOME TOO.
UNLESS YOU ARE A TRUCK DRIVER,
PLUMBER, ELECTRICIAN, THE PEOPLE
WHO LISTEN TO STERN ON THEIR WAY
TO WORK.
THOSE PEOPLE MAKE TWO YEARS
OCCLUSIONS POSSIBLE.
IT'S A POINT I MADE ABOUT THE
MEDIA WHO TELL YOU HOW TO LIVE
WHO DON'T FEEL THE BURDENS OF
THEIR OWN SUGGESTIONS.
LUXURY PEOPLE ON THE SCIENCE AS
WE ARE SITTING IN OUR ISOLATED
BOXES ISN'T REALLY CORRECT.
WHAT MESSAGE ARE WE SENDING
BEING SEPARATE RIGHT NOW?
IT'S TIME TO RETURN TO THE
STUDIO AND START SEEING EACH
OTHER.
GOD, HE IS GORGEOUS.
I COULD SLEEP WITH HIM EVERY
NIGHT.
AND I DO.
ALONE.
THE FACT IS STERN HAD NO SKIN IN
THE GAME BECAUSE HE LEFT THE
GAME ENTIRELY.
HE DIDN'T FEEL THE LONELINESS,
THE SOCIAL SUFFOCATION, THE
ALIENATION AND FLYING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WITH A CHEAP DIAPER ON
YOUR FACE.
THOSE ELASTIC WAIST BANDS MAKE
MY FACE ITCH.
TO BE HONEST, THOUGH, THAT'S A
GOOD STRATEGY ON STERN'S PART.
IN A PANDEMIC, KEEP THE FILTHY
COUSINS AWAY FROM YOUR CASTLE.
BUT NOT EVERYONE CAN DO IT.
IN FACT, NOBODY CAN DO IT EXCEPT
FOR THE KING.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
HE'S THE KIND OF GUY WHO PUTS
RAZOR BLADES IN HIS OWN
HALLOWEEN CANDY.
WESTERN RAZOR.com OWNER DAVID
ANGELO.
DISPARAGE THE SOUTH AND SHE WILL
SMACK YOU IN THE MOUTH.
FOXBUSINESS ANCHOR DAVID DOWELL.
SHE IS ONE KENNEDY WHO WON'T
LEAVE YOU DEAD IN THE WATER.
POST OF KENNEDY ON FOXBUSINESS,
KENNEDY.
AND LIKE YOUR FAVORITE BOOK FROM
THE LIBRARY, SHE IS ALREADY
CHECKED OUT.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
DAVID, YOU ARE A SUCCESSFUL
HUMORIST, THE PROOF BEING YOU
HAD TO START A RAZOR BUSINESS.
THAT'S THE THING I DO WHEN I
REACH SUCCESS.
START A BUSINESS OUT OF MY
GARAGE.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> IT SO FULFILLING TO BE IN THE
CONSUMER GOODS SPACE NOW.
TO MANUFACTURE IN AMERICA
WESTERN RAZORS.com.
I ALREADY DOMINATED COMEDY.
LET'S DO IT WITH THE HEALTH AND
BEAUTY PRODUCTS.
>> YOU ARE MAKING SOMETHING FOR
ONCE THAT PEOPLE WANT HIM.
I THAT'S IMPORTANT.
I ALWAYS HATE THAT ARGUMENT LIKE
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE OLD STERN
OR PEOPLE HAVE CHANGED.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
IT'S A WEIRD DISCONNECT.
>> HE HASN'T CHANGED.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN CALLING HIM AND
SAYING FOR 40 YEARS.
THIS GUY IS NUTS.
NOW THEY SAY WE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT HOWARD.
HE NEEDS HELP.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU I'M A LITTLE
SYMPATHETIC BECAUSE WHAT YOU
SAID IS CORRECT.
I AM ALSO A GERMOPHOBE.
I JUST HAVE A SMALLER APARTMENT.
I HAD TO GO OUT.
>> YOU ARE BASICALLY A RECLUSE,
BUT NOT BY CHOICE.
>> I CANNOT AFFORD IT.
HOW CAN YOU LIVE IN NEW YORK AND
NOT BE DISGUSTED ALL THE TIME?
YOU SEE A GUY WIPING HIS ON THE
SUBWAY AND I AM SUPPOSED TO BE
CONSIDERED NEUROTIC FOR NOT
WANTING TO TOUCH ANYTHING?
>> TO BE FAIR, JESSE WATTERS
DOESN'T HAVE A PRIVATE BATHROOM.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
I AM DISGUSTED 80% OF THE TIME
THAT I AM IN NEW YORK CITY.
MAYBE YOU CHANGED MY MIND.
I THINK YOU ARE STILL WRONG.
I WILL SAY THIS.
I THANK GOD FOR HOWARD STERN.
HE DOES MAKE ME FEEL NORMAL BY
COMPARISON.
I AM LIKE A FOX RECLUSE.
I DON'T DO ANYTHING OR GO
ANYWHERE.
HE MAKES ME LOOK LIKE PETE
DAVIDSON.
>> HE'S A GERMOPHOBE.
HIS WIFE RESCUES CATS.
THAT'S HER JOB, APPARENTLY.
HER THING.
YOU CAN GET TOXOPLASMOSIS OR
CRYPTOSPORIDIUM HOUSES.
>> WHAT ARE THE CHANCES I GET
THAT AGAIN?
>> A LOT OF RELATED.
GIARDIA, RINGWORM.
>> THAT IS SUCH A GREAT NAME FOR
A LEAD SINGER.
>> I GOT IT FROM STREAM WATER
ONES.
IT WAS ATROCIOUS.
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY CALLED IT?
WHEN A GUY IS STANDING OVER YOU
IN A CLUB, THAT IS NOT STREAM
WATER.
>> THAT PAYS REALLY WELL.
DON'T KNOCK IT UNTIL YOU'VE
TRIED IT.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU ARE A
GERMOPHOBE AND LIVE IN NEW YORK
CITY.
THERE ARE PEOPLE LIKE STERN WHO
HAVE BARELY LEFT THEIR
APARTMENTS EXCEPT TO SMOKE ON
THE STREET FOR THE LAST TWO AND
A HALF YEARS.
YOU CAN SEE THEM BECAUSE WHEN
YOU ARE WALKING TOWARDS THEM
THEY ALWAYS DO THIS.
AND THEY LOOK AT YOU LIKE YOU
ARE SOME SORT OF GIANT WALKING
CONTAGIOUS TUMOR.
HERE IS HOW YOU ENSURE THAT THEY
STAY IN THEIR APARTMENT FOREVER.
YOU COUGH, SNEEZE, DO A NOSE
PICK OR DO THE 1-2 PUNCH WHICH
IS THIS AND THIS AND YOU COME AT
THEM.
YOU WON'T BE SEEING THAT ON
SPECIAL REPORT.
>> KENNEDY, YOU LOOK MARVELOUS.
THEY HAVE A SALE AT SPENCER'S
GIFTS?
I ONLY SAY THAT BECAUSE IT'S
TRUE.
I HAVE A THEORY.
WHEN LIFE IS SO GOOD, YOU BECOME
MORE AND MORE TERRIFIED OF
LOSING IT.
I THINK IT'S ABOUT A PROFOUND
FEAR OF DEATH WHICH INCREASES
WITH HIS WEALTH AND PRESTIGE.
IT'S LIKE HE DOESN'T THINK IT
WILL GET ANY BETTER THAN BEING
HERE.
>> TO YOUR POINT, HOWARD HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THIS WAY.
HE HAS ALWAYS BEEN MAKING HIS
CAREER ON NEUROSIS.
HE HAS BEEN VERY HONEST ABOUT
GOING TO ANALYSIS.
NOT JUST THERAPY.
FIVE DAY A WEAK ANALYSIS.
HE'S BEEN UNHINGED AND NUTS AND
OBSESSED WITH.
>> WHO IS LIKE THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S SO WEIRD THAT IT TAKES
ONE TO KNOW ONE.
>> I AM JUST FASCINATED WITH THE
DIGESTIVE SYSTEM.
>> IS THAT WHAT YOU CALL IT?
IT'S THE VERY END OF THE SYSTEM.
>> THAT'S WHERE ALL THE ACTION
IS.
STUDENT THAT'S WHY I AM SITTING
DOWN.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I HAVE TO SAY I GOT INTO
BROADCASTING BECAUSE OF HOWARD.
I WAS AN INTERN AT A RADIO
STATION WHEN HE CAME ON THE AIR
IN LOS ANGELES IN 1991.
THEY WOULD SIMULCAST STARTING AT
3:00 IN THE MORNING WHICH WAS
6:00 IN THE MORNING IN NEW YORK.
I WOULD STAY UP TO LISTEN TO THE
FIRST THREE HOURS OF HIS SHOW.
BEFORE THAT EVERYTHING WAS A
MORNING ZOO.
THIS IS WHAT BROADCASTERS ARE
CAPABLE OF.
HE INSPIRED ME SO DEEPLY THAT I
WANTED TO GET ON THE AIR AND GET
INTO RADIO.
HE HAD ME ON HIS SHOW VERY EARLY
ON AT MTV.
HE HUMILIATED ME AND IT WAS ONE
OF THE GREATEST DAYS OF MY LIFE.
I LOVE HIM AND WILL ALWAYS HAVE
A SOFT SPOT.
>> CAT, BASICALLY IF YOU WORK
FROM HOME IN A REALLY NICE PLACE
YOU SHOULD PROBABLY NOT BE
LECTURING HOW OTHER PEOPLE
SHOULD SPEND THEIR PANDEMIC.
>> YES.
GOOD THING YOU TOOK SEVEN
MINUTES TO SAY THAT.
I THINK IT IS.
I THINK THAT IS TRUE.
I ALSO THINK IT'S STILL KIND OF
SAD, THOUGH, BECAUSE HE IS JUST
THERE.
HE BASICALLY KIDNAPPED HIMSELF.
HE DID.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING THEY WANT TO
SEE HIM.
JIMMY KIMMEL SAID I TAKE TWO
TESTS TO BE ABLE TO COME INSIDE
BECAUSE THERE IS NO DISTANCE AND
CAPABLE IN THAT GIANT COMPOUND.
I THINK IT'S REALLY SAD.
I GUESS THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT
UNTIL I FOUND OUT IT WAS FULL OF
CATS.
>> BUT WE ARE BURYING THE LEAD.
JENNIFER ANISTON AND JUSTIN
THOREAU WERE AT THE SAME DINNER.
ARE THEY BACK TOGETHER?
>> I HOPE NOT.
>> AM I THE ONLY ONE WHO
BELIEVES IN LOVE.
>> WE WILL GET TO THAT.
>> BEFORE WE GO I WILL BE IN
SUGAR LAND.
THAT AIN'T NO EUPHEMISM.
SUGAR LAND, TEXAS ON NOVEMBER
19TH WITH SPECIAL GUEST TOM
SHILLUE AND SOMEBODY ELS